i mean the the whorishness of the media
knows no bounds it is
astonishing i'm just going to read you a
series of headlines these headlines have
been threaded over twitter by david
harsanyi who writes for national review
and new york post it is these are pretty
amazing okay here we go you ready
this one uh gotta love this one all the
times joe biden's love for ice cream
melted our hearts how about this one
from cnn politics
joe biden and kamal harris drop a
playlist for your inauguration watch
party
wow wow and then there was that vogue
cover remember there was a vote cover of
kamala harris and there was an entire
debate in the media over whether it was
too disrespectful of kamal harris
because i remember those sorts of
debates over donald trump were the uh
were the covers of donald trump
as like a pin cushion were those
respectful but we got kamala harris
in this kind of weird pose standing in
front of a
pink curtain wearing her converse and
this is considered disrespectful even
though it literally says on the cover of
vogue
by the people for the people the united
states of fashion
madam vice president kamala harris and
the new america
journalisming up the wazoo then we had
of course jane paulie
remember sitting down with kamala harris
and um and looking all weird because she
had to mirror
the awkward pathological laughter that
kamala harris
spews from her face every time she uh
she says something weird
hey the washington post headline today
most people know her as jill biden
but to some she is dr b the
compassionate and challenging educator
who went the extra mile wow
wow incredible by the way stephen
colbert
yeah last night cut an entire music
video about how
melania trump is the worst person in the
world she didn't do anything she was
just there for four years but she's
michelle obama the greatest hillary
clinton the greatest
melania just horrifying horrifying glenn
kessler of the washington post
won't get ready for reality grounded
white house press briefings yes yes i
remember all those reality grounded
white house press briefings where jay
carney and chen sackey just lied
consistently to you and robert gibbs
they just lied over and over and over to
you but you guys didn't care because you
were too busy performing
unspeakable acts upon the administration
um also this is one of my favorites
lauren wolfe is an editor at the new
york times she deleted this tweet
okay she deleted the sweet because it
was even too awkward for her
she tweeted out a picture of of
president-elect biden arriving at joint
base andrews
and then above it she wrote biden
landing at joyce joint base andrews now
i have chills
wow i'll have what she's having exciting
stuff
the washington post in fashion joe biden
and kamal harris display
their common ground amazing
of a journalist named shimon propex let
the healing begin
we have needed this needed a senile old
man running the government
and encroaching upon our fundamental
right we needed it
it just solid stuff james homan another
journalist
he's the healer in chief the healer in
chief that's his job don't you
understand
he's like a shamanistic healer who can
heal him he lays on hands and america is
healed the very moment that joe biden
takes office
all of our all of our wounds are bound
all of the negativity and toxicity of
our politics is ended
also we're going to need some of your
first amendment just a little bit of it
like
just the part where you say you don't
agree we're going to need that part
over at politico biden is about to give
the most important inaugural speech
since lincoln
is he though since lincoln okay well i
hope that he can stumble
i hope he can stumble his way through it
without trump remember for sure
that'll be that'll be exciting
the flip in time is pretty amazing david
chalian over at cnn i think
this may be the best clip so this is cnn
last night and the guy can't control
himself he just cannot control himself
so they show this uh on screen some
video
from the national mall okay and it shows
the from the washington mall
and it shows the uh the they've planted
several hundred thousand flags out there
to signify the deaths from covet
because obviously they can't have lots
of people on the mall right now for both
safety reasons and also because
we are in the middle of a pandemic still
and they they're shining these
bright lights up into the sky uh and
it's very dramatic right it's very
dramatic footage
and david chalian cannot help himself he
can't help himself
he goes to work and here he is working
both himself
and the biden administration
those lights that are that are just
shooting out from the lincoln memorial
along the reflecting pool i look it's
like almost
extensions of joe biden's arms embracing
america it was a moment where the new
president came to town
and sort of convened the country in this
moment of remembrance
outstretching his arms and contrast that
with that video you just saw
of a disgraced president on his way out
at his lowest point
uh in his presidency wow i mean it's
like
he's like he's giving us a big hug and
then awkwardly stroking our hair and
sniffing us
it's just like that like it's like
lights shooting out that wasn't the only
thing shooting out in this particular
clip
amazing amazing stuff david like arms
embraces i don't want the government
embracing me okay
the government should stay far away from
me so last night i had some dinner with
some folks
and a friend was talking about how he
likes the pomp and circumstance of
inaugurations no matter who's being
inaugurated and
i i said i agree that the exiting
president should go to the inauguration
okay trump should go to biden's
inauguration
obama did it for trump didn't matter
they hated each other right that is a
thing that should happen because it does
signify the peaceful transfer power it
is wrong for trump not to do that
however i generally hate pomp and
circumstance with regard to the
presidency despise it i despise it
because it is monarchic
and it is ridiculous i hate it with
regard to the state of the union i've
been perfectly consistent on this
for years and years and years i think
that the president is basically a
plumber i think they should swear him in
the back of a car and then he should go
do some plumbing
i i don't think he's an important person
i don't think that the presidency of the
united states should be treated
as though he is an emperor a god emperor
on earth embracing us with his arms
okay that sort of idolatrous crap is bad
for the country but the media
love it they are into it and again they
can't help themselves today
honestly what's i think what's most
galling to conservatives is not even
biden taking office it's the fact that
we are now
guaranteed four years of gaslighting
where the objective journalists
decide that journalism consists mostly
of of performing favors uh of an
unspeakable type
on the biden administration and and and
then declaring themselves objective
in all of their facets right after four
years of reporting every sniff of a
rumor
unsourced or sourced inside the trump
administration we'll go back to the good
old days of talking about how wonderful
barack obama's fashion sense is and how
he could have played in the nba or
something
right it'll be really really exciting
stuff okay we're going to get to more of
the media's worship abide and then we'll
get to
what exactly biden is planning because
it's not good for the country guys
it ain't good again i'm praying for the
incoming administration just as i prayed
for the trump administration we
literally do that every sabbath in my
synagogue that doesn't mean i expect
that he's going to do good things in
fact i expect he's going to do things
that are deeply damaging to core
american liberties
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button